hello je suis le styliste pour me
trouver tu rentres dans l'appli
messenger et tu table le styliste dû
cliquer sur démarrer pour que notre
aventure commence je t'attends rejoint
vite sur messenger que la france s'est
fait battre par le brésil 3 hier dont
vous vous le savez mais nous nous venons
[Rires]
je crois qu'il faut savoir être beau
joueur et rendre hommage à nos amis
brésiliens à leur musique
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
elle a pu voir
à grande échelle
[Applaudissements]
non parce que je vous explique en fait
moi je suis maître chien en fait donc je
suis venu en tenue un sens là tout va
bien
venu vérifier qu'on dépensait pas trop
c'est quoi cette lumière la table mais
demande un buzzer pour les parterres ça
c'est une petite prime portable et c'est
moi qui la pétanque est pas les
chroniqueur yann est d'occuper les
autres c'est moi qui les paie et puis ça
c'est que des gens que j'ai fait venir
ils ont rien coûté la vie ça ça coûte
rien ça c'est des autres rien alors oui
il équipait le montiel ça coûtera à lui
qu'est ce qu on fait une super émission
je la regarde depuis tout à l'heure
oui c'est à quel sujet mais il est c'est
david luiz
[Applaudissements]
si tu veux faire un petit quart d'heure
vas-y toi c'est toi qui paye où je viens
de dunkerque en fait ici le lycée p-dg
de joker si tu veux aller en interview
[Applaudissements]
julien c'est ce qu'on va faire
non je te propose un truc et je rigole
pas tu vas me dire si tu échoues pas là
dans le mois qui arrive est ce que tu
veux bien que soit ton chroniqueur un
jour à l'atteindre à bord c'est que je
rêve de faire chroniqueurs et à tous ces
souris tous mais ce afin qu à prendre la
place d'un train
[Applaudissements]